à 12h45 c'est patrick lecocq qui vous
présentera le dernier journal mais
auparavant je propose de rester en
compagnie de françois truffaut et de
virginia crespeau veille comprendre
pourquoi
oui en effet antenne 2 ce soir le grand
plaisir de présenter à ses
téléspectateurs l'un des derniers films
de françois truffaut l'histoire d'un
village
alors bien évidemment nous allons parler
de l'histoire d'aller large que ce que
c'est le film que nous diffusons soir et
tout d'abord puisque vous êtes là
françois truffaut merci d'être venu
voudrait satisfaire une petite curiosité
personnelle
vous avez commencé en tant que critique
de cinéma et vous êtes devenu le metteur
en scène de renom que l'on sait est
alors de plus en plus le grand public
commence à vous connaître en tant que
acteur de cinéma lors sont trois choses
différentes 3 métamorphose comment est
ce que vous faites passer de l'une à
l'autre de ces étapes et pourquoi
peut-être oui je ne sais pas vous savez
acteur metteur en scène c'est un peu
complémentaire parce que on peut
quelquefois avoir envie de jouer dans
son propre fils un des rôles où le rôle
principal même éventuellement oui mais
là une grande production qui ne vous
engagez en paix et en vous donnant on
est encore dans le rôle principal film
américain c'était une participation
exceptionnelle parce que j'aimais
beaucoup le metteur en scène qui faisait
ça qu'il avait besoin d'un français qui
préférait même un français qui ne soit
pas un acte et critique la danse est
l'activité la moins intéressante parce
que je pense que le critique c'est quand
même le comme on dit l'inspecteur des
travaux finis voyez c'est pas très
créatif
quoique ça fasse partie aussi il faut
bien des critiques de théâtre des
critiques littéraires aussi des
critiques de cinéma mais mon activité
principale c'est la mise en scène était
content de montrer ce soir ici à
télévision
ce film l'histoire d'un jeune âge qui
est ancien déjà de trois ans les trois
ans et vous avez dit que vous étiez à
fidèle à vos acteurs que vous aimiez
conserver une équipe d'acteurs que vous
connaissiez travailler avec eux alors
qu'on a vu jean pierre léaud dans de
nombreux personnages masculins claude
jade d'héroïne de plusieurs de vos films
alors là pour à des lâches appareils
label adjani pourquoi pourquoi isabelle
adjani c'est un rôle vêtements qu'elle
ne pouvait pas jouer jean pierre léonard
bender du moins dans le tchad c'était
une histoire d'amour qui demandait
un visage nouveau isabelle adjani est
presque la seule française dans ce film
au milieu d'une troupe anglo saxon le
film a été tourné entièrement ville de
guernesey et voilà c'est une histoire de
passion c'est une en général on a des
histoires d'amour dans le sinaï plein
d'histoires d'amour à deux personnages
et cette histoire là m'a retenu surtout
parce que au fond on y voit un seul
personnage vibrer vraiment avec patio
l'autre n'est que sortes de prétextes
presque rider à la leçon d'histoire cet
amour est une idée oui j'aime les istres
aux amarres la chambre vers brest bien
les films les idées 6 les obsessions
voilà les aider des gens que plus rien
ne peut faire dévier de leur trajet
l'affectif et s'il ya une raison aussi
pour laquelle il a fallu dire c'est que
vous êtes tellement vous-même méticuleux
vous avez souhaité voir un petit peu
comment ça allait se passer la diffusion
de votre fille vous avez monté tout à
l'heure aux télé cinéma vous regarder
dans quelles conditions ça va se passer
oui parce que j'ai remarqué que les la
télévision ce qui passe quelquefois un
peu moins bien ce sont les scènes de
nuit
évidemment dans ce film qui est une
histoire d'amour une histoire de
passionnés très intime beaucoup de
scènes se passent la nuit parce que si
je voulais que le film soit mystérieux
il ya un mystère d'un film à tel point
que je ne vous ai pas dit voyez
l'identité exacte des lâches que
connaissent ceux qui ont déjà vu le film
ou ceux qui ont lu beaucoup d'articles
mais peut-être pas tous les fans de marc
parent a lâché et alors comme il ya
beaucoup de scènes de nuit je voudrais
que vous en face très bien le réglage et
du côté des téléspectateurs je leur
demanderai je n'ai absolument pas
d'ordre à donner 10 même de conseils
mais quand même de ne pas regarder le
film en pleine lumière et d'éviter qu'il
y ait des lumières qui se refléterait
sur l'écran du récepteur il faudrait
idéalement voir le film dans les mêmes
conditions qu'au cinéma en éteignant
avec minimum de lumière et nous notre
côté au télé cinéma nous essaierons de
régler le mieux possible
l'internaute des scènes de jour et de
nuit et on va pas faire attendre
davantage les dates heures mais avant
tout je voudrais ailleurs signalé que
leur programme privé ne sera pas
néanmoins terminé après la diffusion de
l'histoire d'adèle h il y aura une
émission de la série les légendaires
vers 22h10 une soirée merci françois
truffaut